now last week you remember we spent most
of that time looking at and manipulating
expressions do you remember what the
expression was and how it is different
to an equation what's the difference in
equation and an expression thank you
Andy cosine that's it simple difference
an equation has an equal sign most
things we were looking at didn't have
those okay now we are finally getting
into equations proper which means yes we
are going to be solving these things so
I want you to remember if I gave you an
equation any equation before we get to
solving these are you getting sick of
this yet what does it really mean to
solve something what is it that you're
doing what is fun way what are you going
to write as your final line come on have
a look at it's a simple one I gave you
some privacy to three negative two
negative three okay by the way
or
let me make a minor point about this
word or actually why don't you just have
another 2 lines just have this written
on the side up in the corner where
you've got your heading it really
matters that you write the word or
they're mathematicians I've already said
once and I'm going to say it again
famously lazy right we will do as little
work as we possible possibly can and we
will write just in terms of symbols and
letters and numbers as little as we
possibly can which means that two
letters can make a really big difference
because we really believe mathematicians
really believe and you really believe in
economy of communications say less but
mean more there are two common things
that you will see instead of the work
order and they are a comma or an ant now
I'm going to suggest in this context but
you write exactly as I've written it and
write it is or don't use a comma and the
reason why is because if you write a
comment I don't know what you really
mean I don't know if you mean all or n
or something else which then leads to
the next question which is why why not
this one why not right
and ah okay so and this comes back to
the question of what is it into song is
I'm searching for values of X that
satisfy this equation that would that
make this first line true agree with
that now I found two of them but it's
copy both of them simultaneously can't
we'll get to some
break-ins man : ex-con assume both of
these values at once so it's one or it's
the other it's not both at the same time
right so to solve equations this is
really really simple
what do you do what did you do to this
line here
I mean is actually sitting to even work
there what did you do in order to get
your solutions out there any suggestions
what might have been a proceeding lines
or this one
I reckon we would have factorize
probably so something like this so what
was it you did to the left-hand side
what's the name of that process we spent
lots of time to you last week that maybe
is solvable what did you do you
factorize very good sent that first
thing when you were to solve equations
you factorize factorizing is really
really useful okay you may not get
something that requires factorization so
if I gave you something like this you
wouldn't need to factorize that there's
nothing really to factor out so what
would you do to that instead of
factorize any suggest I heard expanding
expanding is often useful I don't really
have any brackets to expand it or
product or anything like that right what
else could I do
okay so what you're trying to do is
you're trying to pin this guy in a
corner right that's what your final line
was see there he is the Pro numeral all
by yourself okay so what will we do to
get the pretty move by itself yessiree
okay so I'm going to change the subject
in what might be the first thing I do to
change the subject they actually have
two choices and both of them fine right
you can see there are two numbers in the
way of you having X by itself I heard
half you say add some to website that
works fine alternatively is 3 is also in
the way so you could multiply 3 by both
sides so I am go against fractions I'm
going to multiply because I'm just going
to treat it like that so then what do I
do
from there I'm going to add to any one
just a quick note
what's that 2033 okay what you're using
what you're taking advantage on is what
we call an inverse right in fact you're
doing it twice did you notice from this
line to this line and this line to this
line why was it the intro
multiplication for the person sailor why
do we choose multiplication
why not division yeah okay so we want
this coefficient should just be one and
the way to get there is to overcome this
division do you see that so division you
use multiplication to get rid of that
now what about from line to mm3 what
operation are we trying to overcome
we're trying to overcome subtraction so
we use addition okay good so what we're
going to do is together not only
factorizing but if you want to rearrange
change the subject
what you do is you use inverse
operations
to change the subject I think that was
the phrase that some used exactly okay
perfect so you factorize use inverse
operations I've run out of space but if
you've got one line under there is one
thing that we've kept in mind through
everything here which is that it's an
equation right what he told me they're
keeping a bad equation is that there's
an equal sign there okay
the equal sign is what it is as a person
who devised it said there are no two
things more equal than two equal in
length parallel lines right so the sign
itself is telling you what it is in
other words the left and the right are
the same right so you know when we what
do we do we multiply by three and then
we added 21 the key was since you
started off with two things that are
equal to each other then you should keep
it equal all the way a nice easy way to
say this is that you have to keep both
sides your left-hand side and your
right-hand side balanced right so you
know how we say use inverse operations
the key to making tree actually arrives
at the right solution is not just by
using inverse operations but by using
the same one every time left hand right
hand side multiply both left hand right
hand side add to both